vous n'êtes pas ici on n'est pas là la
voiture a explosé
aller chercher les fiches de rester ici
avec Audrey je suis pas le chauffeur je
suis le grand-père où êtes-vous
astéroïde 120
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaque année nous fêtons la journée de
la stéroïde commémorant le 23 septembre
Jésus-Christ lorsque la météorite de la
replays a percuté la terre
[Applaudissements]
vous étiez excellente dans le rôle de la
traînée dans le bordel qui a une amnésie
et qui devait être vous étiez vraiment
tous les personnages que j'ai joué c'est
celui que je préfère pourquoi personne
d'autre là aimer
que signifie ces pulsations
de nos informations sur l'espace ne sont
plus tout à fait d'actualité mais en
tout cas il y a toujours 9 planètes dans
le Système solaire est-ce qu'on sache
oui Billy mais maintenant il y a un
alien
que se passe-t-il encore je n'en sais
rien j'aime pas la manière dont il nous
a regardé l'alien comment il comment il
vous a regardé comme si c'était foutu
d'avance c'est peut-être le cas
ils peuvent nous garder à astéroïde City
je veux dire légalement le monde sera
plus jamais le même amalienne qui fait
des pompes un alien avec un haut de
forme il y a quoi là-haut le sens de la
vie peut-être qu'il y en a un
mes enfants tu es en train de dire que
notre mère est morte il y a trois
semaines disons qu'elle est au paradis
qui n'existe pas pour moi bien sûr mais
vous êtes épices pas bien dans ma
solitude j'ai appris à offrir une fois
totale et inconditionnelle à tous les
gens que j'aime alors je ne sais pas si
tu en fais partie mais ça incluait ma
fille et vos quatre enfants parfois je
pense que je me sentirai plus chez moi
en dehors de l'atmosphère terrestre
moi aussi ils sont étranges n'est-ce pas
vos enfants
comparé au gamin normaux c'est exact
[Musique]
je voulais dire oui mais ma bouche n'a
pas parlé
[Musique]